Greetings. All right, well, our next
session hey, Bert. Greetings.
Great. Hey, how you doing? Good, good.
Very well. Our next session is with Bert
DeVries, Dmitri Baghev, and Bart Van
ERP. It's going to be called towards
User Friendly Design of Synthetic Active
inference agents. And I know a lot of
people are super excited to see this
really practical and cutting edge work.
So to you, Bert, and just let us know
how we can support. Okay, great.
Is my audio good? Yep, sounds good.
Okay, then I'm going to share my screen.
I hope I picked the right one. I don't
work with zoom quite often. Looks good.
Looks good. Yeah. All right. Super.
Well, thanks a lot, Daniel, for hosting
this symposium. I've been watching some
talks. It's really amazing. And we feel
privileged to get a chance to present
ourselves. So we are also, just like a
few others before us, interested in
developing a toolbox for active
inference. And so this picture,
or she kind of shows what we're
about or what we are interested in. So
here's a lady on the left hand side,
and I'm going to try to get a laser
pointer. And she has this idea about a
rewarding behavior for a vacuum cleaning
robot, right? So she's writing down she
has a textual expression. Move around
the apartment, apply suction until the
floor is clean, do not touch objects,
and when done, return to the dog. So
that's not so hard. I'm going to rate
that with one star out of three stars in
terms of difficulty level to specify
that. But that's not enough to program
this robot, right? Because what she
really needs to do now is to specify a
generative model and there's
effectors and actuators, right. The
robot has to move around, apply suction
until the floor is clean. So there are
sensors, probably a camera. Do not touch
objects. Or maybe there has to be object
recognition. This is a really difficult
task to come up with this generative
model here. And on top of that, she has
to specify this kind of rewarding
behavior in terms now of probability
distributions of this generative model.
So very difficult. I'm going to rate
that with two stars because the
next thing she has to do for this model
is to specify the inference procedure to
do actually active inference and free
energy minimization in real time for
this complex model. And really that's
almost impossible, right? Only a few
specialists can really write a procedure
for variational free energy minimization
in some very difficult model. So what
we are about what we've been working on
is to try to automate the inference
task. So get rid of the three stars.
And yes, she will still have to specify
her model, but in the long term, we try
to get away from that. So in the long
term, we hope we will get a toolbox.
And now we're talking 510 years, right,
where a textual description would be
enough to specify some initial model
with an initial prior and everything
else is just automated inference,
learning of states, parameters,
structural adaptation of the model,
even maybe based on her feedback
updating the prior.
So that's long term for now,
we would be very happy if we could just
automate the inference task.
So why is it so difficult to specify
inference for an active inference agent?
Well, we have so many competing KPIs,
right? We want to do this for large
model scopes, not just for ABCD models,
but maybe there's also continuous
variables and hierarchical models,
right? It must be very user friendly.
We really don't want her to worry about
robustness of her code.
We don't want her to worry about whether
two variables have conjugate
relationships adaptivity. We want to
update states, parameters, maybe even
the model. The model structure has to be
low power because these ancients often
run on edge devices, so they run on
their battery powered has to be in real
time because you can't learn how to ride
a bike if there's no real time
reasoning. And on top of that, you
actually want to minimize variational
frequency, right? You want to do it at
least as good or at least in a
neighborhood of if you would do a manual
derivation. And some of these decidorata
bite each other, right? If you want to
minimize variational free energy, but
you have to do it in real time and on
low power that kind of bites each other,
right? So these are difficult KPIs
that they're all important.
You can't just take one out because then
the whole system wouldn't work. So when
you read papers on active inference,
you often also read and now we implement
variation of minimization and that can
be done by message passing on a graph.
And I want to clarify first why it has
to be done by message passing on the
graph. I do that by giving a very short
answer and then do an example. The short
answer is that Bayesian inference
involves computing very large
sum of products, like what you see here
on the left hand side. Here's a product
AC, ADBC, and then we sum them
AC plus ad and so forth. This is a sum
of products. Now, we know by the
Distributive law that this here on the
left hand side can also be computed as
on the right hand side. If I multiply
this out, I get a times C plus a times D
and so forth. This is a product of sums
and they're exactly the same thing. The
only difference is that to compute the
left hand side takes four additions
sorry, four multiplications and three
additions. To compute the right hand
side takes two additions and only one
multiplication. So on the right hand
side is much cheaper to compute than the
left hand side. Normally when we write
down marginalization and Beijing
inference, we write things down as in
the left hand side what message passing
does on the graph, it will automatically
convert that into much cheaper to
evaluate product of sums. And I'll give
an example of that.
So here is an example model F
of seven variables x one, x two through
x seven. And this model happens to be
factorized FA of x one, FB, x two and so
forth. Now, we can draw this
factorization as a graph. And what
we do, and this is called a Farney style
factor graph, what we do is for each
factor FA, we allocate a node.
So FB gets a node and FC gets a node.
And we associate the variables in our
system with the edge. And an edge is
connected to a node if that variable is
an argument of that function. So FC is
a function of x one, x two, x three.
And that means that FC connects to the
edges x one, x two, x three, and FD
is only a function of x four. So FD only
connects to the edge x four. So what
you can see in this graph is this graph
is nothing but a visualization of
the factorization assumptions that we
have for this model. Now, if I'm
interested in a big marginalization task
and I integrate out over all variables
but x three, so x one, x two,
x four and so forth through x seven,
I'm interested in this. Then taking
advantage of this factorization, I can
rewrite basically this sum
of product into a product of sums
as below here, what you will
see here below this computes exactly the
same thing. But I've made use of this
distributive law. For instance,
FC contains no x four,
no x five. So I moved it over the
summation sign to the left. And FB also
doesn't contain x four, x five, x six,
seven. So I moved it all the way to the
left. And when you do that, you are left
here with an expression where I
only sum over two variables
and here I have to sum over six
variables and here over two, and here
over two. So you can imagine if each
variable, let's say x one, x two,
if each variable has ten interesting
values that you need to sum over, then I
have here the original marginalization
problem. I have ten to the power six,
so a million terms, and here in
red I have 100 terms and here I have 100
and here I have 100. So here I have 300
terms and here I have 1 million terms.
So it's an enormous reduction in
computational complexity when
we make use of this distributive law.
Now, it turns out that if you write this
out, you can associate these
intermediate factors with messages on
the graph. It's just an interpretation,
a visual interpretation. It's as if FC
receives a message from FA and FB
receive or FC receives a message from FB
and computes an outgoing message MU x
three. And the same thing for Fe. So Fe
receives a message from its neighboring
factors, FD and FF and computes an
outgoing message, x three.
So what you see here is that the entire
marginalization process can be
represented as basically computing a few
messages on a graph and multiplying some
of these messages with each other. And
that's how you can do Bayesian inference
and also how you can do variational free
energy minimization. So this works in
factorized models, but I would say even
stronger if your model is not factorized
and you have a lot of variables, there
is just no way you can do proper
inference. So any serious model is
factorized, like the brain is almost
sparse, is almost empty. We have, what
is it, about 10 billion neurons, and
each neuron connects to a few thousand
other neurons. So if I would draw the
graph, that graph is almost empty, it is
hugely sparse. And so there is no other
way to do inference in the brain than by
message passing. So that's why message
passing, just because it's more
effective than anything else.
Now then the issue is which message do
you compute? How do you compute
messages? Because there are
different ways of doing it right. And we
also read in active inference papers,
you can do this by variational message
passing, or expectation maximization,
or belief propagation and variational
LaPlace and all these terms. It turns
out that there is an umbrella framework
for all these methods passing
frameworks. And that umbrella framework
is called Constraint better free energy
minimization. And I will try to
illustrate it by this slide.
So here I have this graph. This is just
an example graph where my generative
model is basically factorized
in FA, FB, FC, FD and
Fe. And I've also written that here. So
this now is the variational free energy.
Now, I haven't made any assumption on Q
of X. So Q of X is still Q of x one, x
two, x three. It's just a joint overall
variables and it doesn't have any
factorization assumption. It makes sense
to also assume that the posterior kind
of follows the factorization assumption
of the prior, namely of the generative
model. So if we make that assumption and
that means we're going to make the
assumption that QX is also now a product
of QAS of X of A, where QAS
of X of A stands for beliefs over nodes.
What I mean by that is that Q of B is
a posterior belief over this node,
meaning it's a posterior belief over the
edges that connect to this node. Just
like FB is a function of x one, x two,
x four, that's if you will, the prior or
the generative model, then Q of B, the
variational posterior for this node will
also depend on x one, x two, x four,
and on no other factors.
If you just do that, then you will count
some of the variables double because x
one is part of the belief over FA,
but also part of the belief over FB. So
we just have to discount that by
dividing by beliefs over edges.
That means that I make now an assumption
that my posterior beliefs is
divided into local beliefs over notes
and local beliefs over edges over
variables. This will make things a lot
simpler. In fact, if my graph is a tree
and I did the tree here, and I would do
message passing on that tree and I could
suppose I could do that perfectly,
everything is linear gaussian, then I
get perfect Bayesian inference. There is
no approximation. So this is a good
assumption. Sometimes it's still very
hard to compute a message because even
the single messages that come out of
these nodes, they're still integrals or
summations, and in particular the
integrals may be a problem. We may not
have an analytical answer. So what we
sometimes do is add additional
assumptions. We'll say, well, the
posterior belief over FD, I can't
compute it in general, but I'm going to
just assume now that it's a gaussian
that makes it easier. Or we can make an
extra factorization assumption and
say the posterior belief over FB,
which is really a belief over the joint
x one, x two, x four is going to be
broken into independent
belief over x one and belief over x
two and x four.
These additional assumptions, if I
impose them as well, this is what I
recall. Now, if I all substituted here
in Q of x, I get what's called a
constrained beth free energy. This is
the same Beth as in the Oppenheimer
movie. This is Hans Bethe, where it's
named after.
We have a graph now that
is highly factorized and we have local
beliefs over notes and over
and they're indicated with red and we
have additional constraints in green.
They could be Gaussians or mean field
constraints or other constraints. And
now we will assume constraints that make
it possible to compute all the messages.
And now we can just automate this by
making different assumptions. We can
turn this into expectation maximization
or belief propagation or hybrid
forms thereof. We can turn it into any
relevant message passing algorithm that
you've heard of. So this is a very nice
umbrella framework that basically
encompasses everything.
We've written a pretty large paper on
this in the Entropy Journal where
you can read all the math on how this
works. So we've talked about
why message passing, namely because it's
the most effective way of doing
inference. And we've talked about which
messages to compute, namely we turn
our variational free energy into
something called a constraint, better
free energy and then we can compute
messages. The only thing that's left is,
well, when do we pass these messages?
What is the sequence of messages? Which
one comes first? And this is
where we see a lot of papers, right?
You have to write control flow, what's
called control flow. You have to say,
okay, here is my algorithm for active
inference. First I specify a model.
Then let's do inference for every time
step, collect a new observation, update
the state, update the desired future,
and so forth, compute expected free
energy, select the policy, et cetera.
This kind of program. The problem with
active inferences is that there is
nested for loops in here. Here's a for
loop, and here's another for loop. And
for each of these policies, I'm going to
have to go into the future, so I'm going
to have another time loop. So it is for
loops, in for loops, in for loops. This
will completely explode in terms of
computational complexity.
So as a result, some very clever people
have written very clever algorithms of
doing this much faster. Sophisticated
inference, branching time active
inference, dynamic programming EFE are
recent proposals for doing this very
clever. In the end, all of these
proposals come down to a particular
just a message passing schedule.
Once we commit to message passing on the
graph as our inference procedure, it's
the only thing that's going on. And all
of this sophisticated inference and
branching time active inference, all it
does is it schedules the messages. It
says first this message, then this
message, then this message. I don't mean
that as a slight to these algorithms.
They're very clever. And as we've seen
in the presentation by Aswin Paul, you
get huge improvements if you go from
regular inference to sophisticated
inference. But it's good to realize that
these algorithms just specify in a graph
which message comes after which message.
So here's an example of
a graph and a message sequence.
Here's message one, then message two,
and message three goes up, and then we
go from FC to FF, and here's message
five, and then we go to Fe. And this
could correspond this sequence to
dynamic time programming EFE or
sophisticated inference. There are a
couple of problems with this approach,
which basically with having the user to
specify a clever algorithm, first of
all, you have to be a specialist to do
it right. Only these are very clever
people. That means that if we let
it leave it to say to
an engineer in a company, well, it's a
high probability he's not going to get
it right. That's very unfortunate. But
there is another issue, and that is that
in a sense, it's a global variable in
the message passing schedule. All nodes
are visited, because if a node would not
be visited, then we shouldn't have it in
the graph. And that means if one node
crashes, basically the message passing
schedule is invalid. I have to reset my
system. And if you fly a drone, if it's
deployed and it's out in the field and a
node crashes, a transistor burns out,
and I have to totally reset now my
system, I have to compute a new message
passing schedule. Then you're not doing
inference and your drone flies into the
wall. So this is not robust.
And it also for the same reason
we may actually want to take out a node.
We may want to prune a node, we want to
do structural adaptation. And we
can't do structural adaptation because
we have to reset the system, recompute a
message passing schedule. So this
procedural style where an engineer
specifies which message comes after this
message has some disadvantages. It's not
very robust. And if you want to do it
very clever, you have to be really a
specialist. So a better system
is what we call reactive message
passing. And it's very related
to what was in the first session called
the actor model. Keith Duggar had a nice
presentation on the actor model. So what
we will do is we will say we will not
have a global message passing schedule.
The engineer will not specify anything
anymore. The inference code that an
engineer will have to write is just say,
react to any free energy minimization
opportunity. In other words, there is no
inference code. It's completely
automated. And we will replace
this global message passing schedule by
local triggering inside the node. So
each node is now just an autonomous
system that's interested in minimizing
its free energy. It can do so by sending
out messages. And when will it do so?
Well, it receives messages, and then
when it looks at these messages and it
feels like, oh, there is an opportunity
for me to minimize free energy by or
expected free energy energy by sending
out a message. Then we'll send out a
message and each node will do so by
itself asynchronously so you get
parallel distributed processing, or
concurrent processing, as Keith called
it. In principle, you could play this
game on many computers at the same time,
and so you get tremendous advantages.
First of all, you don't have to write
difficult code. Second of all, you can
do multithreading or you can
run it on multiple computers at the same
time. And there's also
robustness advantages
because if a node crashes, then there's
nothing that stops the system from just
finding another path, right? If this
node crashes, this path from here's
message three, this path now doesn't
work. So I cannot send anything to Fe
anymore from X. Well, then I
just sent a new message here. Why not?
It's like when water falls down a
mountain and it zigzags its way down
into the value and you halfway put up an
obstruction. It just finds another path,
not the preferred path. This has
to find, well, the second best path,
because the first path has been
obstructed, right? And that's what's
going to happen in this system as well,
right? That's just how nature works. It
tries to find the best path, the easiest
path, and if that's not available, then
we do the second best path. And that's
also what you can do with reactive
message passing. So you can prune nodes.
You can do structural adaptation,
and it's far more robust. And you can
also do chance encounters
with other drones, right? Drones that
get close can start communicating with
each other, and when they fire away,
they stop communicating with each other.
And this is no problem, because you can
basically change who
change nodes
can change on the fly, who they
communicate to and who they want to
listen to. That's the
way nature works, and also how it works
when we do reactive programming and
reactive message passing. So,
in summary, we're interested in
automating inference, in active
inference agents, right? Because it's
an operation that's basically only for
experts. And this active inference
technology is not going to be successful
unless we get more people, let's say,
democracies it, and we get competent
engineers being able to develop good
agents, right? You shouldn't have to be
a top specialist in the world to develop
an active inference agent. Now, in order
to automate inference, you must do
message passing, and I've talked about
that for efficiency. I've also talked
about which messages to pass. Not
necessarily do you have to follow this
framework, but constrained better Free
energy framework is very convenient.
It's an umbrella framework that
basically goes over
all the interesting other message
passing computations. When message
passing, reactive message passing, it's
fully automated, so you don't have to
write any code anymore. In principle,
you can do parallel distributed
processing. It's robust structural
changes. You can learn new inference
pathways. So lots of advantages here.
Now, how do we do it? I like
to introduce a toolbox that we've been
working on called ARX infer. And we
do that with my lab here at the
university. I'm here in Eindhoven in the
south of the Netherlands, and we have a
lab. The lab is called BIS lab. Here are
postdocs and assistant professors and
PhD students, and we've been working on
this for many years. And some of these,
like Albert and Ismail and Tyce,
have written dissertations. And our
best work, we have consolidated that in
a toolbox. And the toolbox is called
Arcs infer. And if you want to have a
look, you can go to the website,
arcsinfer. ML. And Arctinfur
works in the way that I've just
discussed. It does message passing. It
tries to minimize constraint, better
free energy. That means it can come up
with all kinds of message passing
algorithms. It will do it in
a reactive way, and it will try to do it
in real time and low power and all the
KPIs that we're talking about. Now,
it's, of course, not done, but it's
functional and like to show some
demos. And I will leave it to Dimitri
and Bart, who are two advanced PhD
students in my lab to show the demos.
So I'm going to stop sharing.
Awesome. Thank you, Bert. Great talk.
Sure. Can you hear?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I will try to
share my screen. Okay.
So you should see it now. Looks good.
Okay, so, yeah, hello to everyone,
I'm admitry. Baghaiv so I'm a PhD
student in Bioslab in Einhoven
University of Technology, and yes, I
have a small presentation about actual
software developments in so
over the past few years, we have
significantly improved our tools. And
basically my entire PhD was dedicated to
implement this idea, which Beard was
talking about, like implementing the
variation of reactive message passing.
And in this presentation, I just want to
show you what you can actually do using
this theory under the hood. Okay,
so basically, in order to automate
active inference, we need to automate
Bayesian inference. And we have already
a lot of solutions for that, such as
Pyro NumPy, which is funded by Google,
Info. Net is funded by Microsoft,
turing is in July, PIMC, and many,
many. And basically these
solutions are really good and they're
really good at prototyping as well. But
our goal is eventually to be able to
deploy these kind of systems, not just
prototype. And we are really focusing on
these particular properties for this
automated Bayesian inference. So it must
be low power, adaptive, real time
scalable. It also must be user friendly
at the end and must support a large
scope of models if we want it to be
useful. In Bioslab,
we want to build such a software with
such nice properties and
it's always about trade offs, right? So
we do something better in one particular
domain and maybe other software
libraries, they might be better in a
different domain, but we are really
focusing on this particular property.
And so, yes, I will reiterate a little
bit Bert's presentation. So how do we
achieve this? So imagine we have an
environment and we have an agent, and
the agent takes some actions and the
agent basically what he needs is to come
up with some sort of good enough
probabilistic model of its environment
in order to do patient inference.
And in our framework, we encode the
model as a factor graph, which not only
models the observations, but also
actions and desired future.
And this approach allows us to decompose
these complex relationships between
variables and hidden states into some
kind of structure and local blocks.
And it's not a black box anymore.
And the model itself may have some sort
of background motivation interpretation.
It may encode your prior knowledge about
some particular physical system and
the locality of these blocks basically
allows you to scale to millions of
variables and hidden states. It allows
you to pre optimize it maybe, or maybe
use some sort of different approximation
strategies in different places. So it
allows a lot of very nice properties as
well. And we use reactive message
passing to run actual variational
Bayesian inference. It uses reactive
programming under the hood to minimize
the approximation to the variational
free energy. And yes, as Bert also
mentioned, it's very much related to
actor model. And basically
in Ariks and fur. You can think of
different nodes as actors themselves and
they have basically one single purpose
is to send a variational message that
minimizes free energy. This is a very
short and very high level description,
but it is essentially what is happening
under lipid. So we are not treating
different agents which interact with
each other as actors, but we also treat
the actual components of the underlying
model as actors themselves. It's like a
very hierarchical structure. So this is
the main central idea of this
inference. So here
for example, first example, we can do an
inference in a dynamical system. This
example, which is quite old already, I
think it's like two years ago. So we
track a position of the object given
some noisy measurements which are
indicated by green dots, the actual real
signal, we cannot observe it, but we
just can plot. It is shown as blue and
the inferred signal is shown as red and
the data set is infinite. The inference
end just reacts on it and does not
assume any particular data size. Simply
reacts in your observation as soon as
possible. Yeah, I'm actually not sure
how smoothly Zoom shares my screen.
Maybe you can see it's a bit lagging in
the animations, I'm not sure because
maybe zoom does not share it on a full
frame rate. And also on the right hand
side you can see how we define models in
our framework. We use Julia as a
programming language. Basically,
this is everything that you need to
define this particular model and run
inference on a data set. And actually I
literally spent more days to plot it
instead of inference. So inference was
an easiest part for me, plotting was way
much harder to relate to user
friendliness. And we actually have
plans to improve our model specification
language, make it even easier. So now
for technical reasons, we have some
auxiliary statements in the model
specification language, but we are
working to improve that and make it even
easier. This is another
example which is similar to the previous
one, that uses much more complex and
linear dynamical system of the double
pendulum. And the system is chaotic and
we can observe only a small part of it
with a lot of noise, also indicated as a
green dots. And nevertheless,
given good enough model, you can infer
the other hidden states with pretty much
high precision and the code needed for
that is also relatively short.
We also have examples with active
inference agents that interact with
their environment. So the
left up shows mountain
car problem, very famous problem. The
left bottom side shows an active
inference agent which tries to control
the inverted pendulum from falling in
the windy conditions it reacts in wind.
We also have a demo of an agent that
controls a pendulum in an ever changing
environment. So on the right side you
see a pendulum with an engine and engine
has limited power and. The agent itself
needs to reach the goal and the goal is
indicated as a red circle.
Basically, in this demo we can change
the environment in real time and see how
the agent reacts. So we can change the
mass of the pebble among its length or
the amount of noise in the measurements,
or we can change the goal, we can change
maximum engine power, et cetera. So the
agent will still try to infer the best
possible course of actions in order to
reach its goal and it just never stops
reacting. It's also actually possible
to restrict engine power such that it
will not longer possible to reach the
goal, right? But the agent will still
try. We have
other cool demos with smart navigation
and collision avoidance which are still
under active research and the code for
them is not available publicly it will
be soon available, but for example in
this example we can define a set of
agents with their boundaries and a set
of their destinations. And we can see
how they try to resolve their routes
altogether.
And we can have some static obstacles in
the map. We can see how agents can find
their most optimal path in order
to reach their goals and avoid any
possible collision. And it's also not
necessary to have static obstacles, the
obstacles themselves may move. So on
this demo we have hundreds of agents
that navigate through a map of obstacles
that move from bottom to top to the
circles or obstacles. And agents are
depicted as small dots and they need to
go from left to right, basically avoid
any sort of collision.
And as I also mentioned, we want to
perform efficient and real time
inference, but we also to do it like low
power, low performance on low
performance devices such as Raspberry,
Pi or Coolpy as an example. And we have
some results of successfully running the
Bayesian audio source separation, for
example, on coolpy. So it is actually
possible we try
to run active inference agents also on
Coolpy. So as the aforementioned
inverted pendulum, and as
I mentioned, we also need to
have a large model scope and basically
RICS infer has not been designed to
solve any of the aforementioned
problems. Specifically, we have a large
set of different examples in our
repository, different models, different
data, different inference constraints.
We have examples for linear regression,
hidden Markov model altogether, grace
model hierarchy models, misheard models,
Gaussian process and so, right? So this
approach is very versatile.
And for example, if you
compare it with sort of a conventional
software libraries where you let's say
have a library that solves a common
filter, might be a very great library,
maybe super fast, have top performance
works great and very reliable,
super good. But then you are constrained
by this particular model common
filtering, right? And you can't really
change it much. In Ericsson Fur we
are free to define our own models which
we can pretty much easily define a model
that essentially would act equivalently
to common filtering equation. And so
basically in the demo that I showed
before about object tracking, it was
essentially a common filter but was
written in a probabilistic model.
So yeah, that was my small addition to
Bear's presentation. So our software is
free MIT license and it's open source
available on GitHub. Yeah, and we would
be happy thanks to be able to present
where we would be happy to answer. Any,
thanks.
Awesome. All right, I'll just ask a
quick question. In the chat Marco asks
sorry if I missed it are the collision
avoidance demos real time adapting to
other agents behavior or is it a
collectively pre computed path?
So basically they are not super real
time, they're kind of fast to compute
this path, like maybe 5 seconds or so.
But we are basically working to make it
real time. So we know what is the
problem, we know where to improve and we
will make it real time. Yes, almost.
Next question. Do you have some
comparative data with other methods?
And just more generally, what kinds of
benchmarks or when you're talking with
industry in different settings, what are
people looking for that killer app of
active inference? Or what are they
looking for their key measures?
So I personally have a big paper about
comparison with sampling based methods
like HMC and also in my PhD thesis,
there will be a comparison with nuts,
also other sampling based methods.
So, long story short, sampling based
methods cannot really run this kind of
sophisticated inference in real time.
They're very time consuming. They do not
really scale well to large problems
which is really needed for active
inference agents. Because if you have a
large environment, very complicated,
you will have a lot of unknown variables
in your model.
There is a paper that compares and
basically we show that our approach
scales much, much better. So I
personally run on just a regular MacBook
laptop, I run the model with 2 million
unknown variables and it was quite
fast. With sampling based methods
you may find yourself in a model with
like 100 variables and then you wait
like 2 hours or something and then it
turns out that your chain did not
converge or something like
that.
Cool. Yeah, it's people commenting in
the chat like how far message passing
and factor graphs have come. And so to
Bias Lab and to Bert at all, we
definitely appreciate this exciting line
of research. I mean, there's so much to
learn there and sometimes looking at the
equations, it can seem like it's like
written in stone and just sort of the
beginning and the end is, you know,
variational free energy. But then in
your presentations you're really showing
like no, we are hands on. That's where
we get the interpretability, the
modularity, that's where it really is
implemented. And it's like an
information logistics challenge. It's
not like an esoteric philosophy question
at that point. No,
indeed. I should say it's
taken us we are no geniuses, right.
So our lab exists more than eight years,
and you see all the people in the lab,
it's taken us many years with lots of
wrong directions to get this to work to
where it's now. So it's a very long
path. But at this
moment, I'm pretty confident that at
some point in the future and we
don't want to say in three months or in
one year, but we will be able to write a
toolbox that will allow people to design
a generative model and just press a
button and forget about the inference.
You don't have to worry about inference
anymore. It will be fast and automated,
and that will happen, and it will happen
within a few years. And maybe
somebody else will write an even better
toolbox. But I'm pretty confident that
even our toolbox will be able to do
that. People talk about,
why don't we have the success of deep
learning and generative AI, right?
Well, they have the success because of
big data availability of big data, big
computers and toolboxes TensorFlow and
all the successes. We don't need big
data because agents collect their own
data in the field. We don't need big
computers, active influence agents,
they manage their power resources. But
we need a really good toolbox because
programming an active inference agent,
programming the inference by hand is
just not doable. So we need a really
good toolbox that really automates this.
We hope Arcs Infer will be one of the
first toolboxes to do that. I am sure
that other people will also be working
on it, and better toolboxes will come
about. But I think the optimistic
message is that it will happen. And once
we have a toolbox like that, then we can
actually a large community can start
building agents, and we can actually
show deployable agents in
the field that they work. And they work
better than reinforcement learning agent
or whatever is out there. Right.
So I think that's a very positive and
hopeful message. It's what we expect.
It's what we prefer. Yeah.
Any last comments from either of you?
Comments from us? No, I'm just very
happy to get the opportunity, and yeah,
I want to everybody
can download this toolbox. I think
at this moment, you still should be a
programmer to work with the toolbox.
And I hope you're friendly, because it's
not totally polished in
the way that we want. But it's coming,
right? It's coming. In the next years,
there will be a good toolbox for almost
everybody to use, but people that are
interested, even people that are
interested to work. Here at Biaslab, we
have an open position for PhD students,
so we're happy to receive
emails from people that are interested
to work with us.
Thank you. Dimitri, anything in closing?
No, just that. Thank you again for
possibility to present. Super nice to be
here. Cool. Yeah. Well, later in the
year, we will be discussing your two
part recent work, and so we're going
to be getting a lot into the details,
and I hope that people in the institute
and the ecosystem will be as excited as
we all are. Thank you. Thank you.
Bye.